Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new marvel doctor doom fantastic four video
apparently howard stern leaked news that there
is a doctor doom project happening in the mcu
so i'll explain what's going on in what it was
that he actually leaked if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a giveaway for thor love and
thunder imax tickets too all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and post all your
doctor doom theories in the mcu like what
do you want them to do with that character
but you probably saw all these websites reporting
that howard stern leaked news that there is a
doctor doom project happening like that's
why everybody was set off in the past week
it was all over everyone's feeds a lot of
really big news websites were reporting about it
the clip is a little muddled because it's him
talking on a hot mic like he was revealing things
on live air when he didn't mean to broadcast
it so you have background music playing on
top of his dialogue you can barely hear what
he's saying but you can kind of make it out
you probably recognize some of the things that
were said during that robert downey jr john in
doctor doom what was happening there is a howard
stern was talking to robin when the microphone
was supposed to be off like he didn't mean to be
live on the air when she was asking him what he
was working on this summer outside of his own show
like are you working on any movies or tv shows and
he was telling her yes while also making fun of
himself just jokingly talking about how he was
so afraid of catching the virus and getting sick
he didn't want to leave his house that he turned
into this bunker just to protect himself from the
virus so he was joking about how he'd contracted
to work on this new marvel doctor doom project
that would require him to go to set to film his
part and he was just joking about not wanting to
leave his makeshift bunker that he constructed
making a bunch of comparisons to what he'd done
during his america's got talent episodes that
he'd done if you're not a big fan of howard
stern or you haven't watched his show before
even long before the virus he'd always clowned
on himself for being this huge hypochondriac
so he's been known for really eccentric behavior
for a long long time usually when you hear him
complaining about things like this complaining
about having to do a marvel show like complaining
about doing this doctor doom project it's just him
joking clowning on himself like it's an honor to
be asked to do stuff like this but like he
literally mentions he's going to do doctor
doom but he doesn't say whether it's a movie or a
disney plus tv show people are thinking that he's
talking about a marvel disney plush show because
in the same breath he's comparing his activity to
what he did during america's got talent episodes
that he'd done mostly joking about how it was hard
to work with him because he's so eccentric during
the clip he also says that he called robert downey
jr for acting advice because it's a marvel project
and robert downey jr's appeared on his show many
times like their friends in real life and then the
reason why people are thinking that john favreau
is the john that he talked about calling involved
in this doctor doom project is because in the same
breath where he mentions talking to robert downey
jr and doing this marvel project he also asked
if they had a number for john but john favreau
obviously has deep ties with marvel and disney
he directed the first two iron man movies he just
came back as happy hogan during spiderman no way
home and he's also running the mandalorian and
all the spin-off of the mandalorian series for
star wars and if you didn't realize he often gets
executive producer credits on newer marvel movies
like avengers end game he still consults on some
of those bigger movies that they do marvel has a
big comic-con panel that's happening this summer
and recently they've also been looking for another
director for the fantastic four movie since john
watts dropped out remember he's the director of
all marvel's spider-man movies so far spiderman no
way home being the most recent one originally he
was supposed to direct their brand new fantastic
four movie like he was moving from the spider-man
franchise at marvel to the fantastic four trilogy
or whatever sequel movies they plan on doing with
that but then he dropped out of that and announced
he was doing a special star wars tv series which
is set during a different part of the timeline
from the mandalorian maybe adjacent to when the
mandalorian is happening but it's not meant to be
a spin-off series of john favreau's mandalorian
series also people think that he dropped out of
fantastic four because he's going to come back
and do spider-man 4 because sony's been hyping
up spider-man 4 with tom holland but here's
the thing howard stern gets confused about
stuff like this all the time the john that
he was talking about like do you have a number
for john that he says during the clip he could
have been talking about john watts mistakenly
thinking that he was still part of the project
meaning that he could have just been talking
about actually doing the fantastic four movie
and mistakenly calling it a doctor doom project
or like the scenes that he was preparing to film
were related to doctor doom in this new version
of the fantastic four movie that marvel was doing
because if they're going to introduce a version of
dr dumont on screen it would make sense that they
would do it through this new fantastic four movie
they didn't confirm what the story of the movie is
going to be it won't be the exact same plot as the
classic fantastic four movies or like rise of the
silver surfer or the 2014 fantastic four movie in
all those movies told a pretty regular doctor doom
origin story like he was one of the main villains
if not the main villain of most of those movies
and talk about deleted scenes the funny thing
about the 2014 fantastic four movie is that even
though it turned into a huge debacle the writer of
that movie is the exact same person who just wrote
the marvel moon night episodes he revealed that
in his original script galactus and annihilus were
going to be the original main villains of that
movie it was going to be way crazier the fantastic
four were still going to go to the negative zone
that's an alternate anti-matter universe but in
the negative zone they were going to be way more
comic book accurate and say that they encounter a
version of annihilus in the annihilation wave who
would try to invade their normal universe and also
while they're in the negative zone they were going
to introduce a more comic book accurate version of
galactus at the end of the movie who was going
to follow their signal from the negative zone
back into the normal universe and start consuming
planets like that was going to be one of their big
post-credit scenes assuming that that movie had
done well they would have done sequels the sequel
would have been fantastic four versus a nihilist
and then probably the final film in the trilogy
would have been fantastic four versus galactus
but at the last minute fox got rid of all that to
save money and re-cut the movie into what we saw
in theaters and it turned into the huge debacle
in a weird doctor doom negative zone story now we
try not to think about that but because it was the
same writer from that fantastic four movie during
moon night a lot of people thought that they saw
doctor doom easter eggs during moon night inside
the 616 universe because in the first episode he
winds up in this mysterious secluded eastern
european town that seems very german-like like
lot veria before he understands what's going on
with mark spector being in control of the body or
knowing about konchu waking up after he had just
stolen the scarab and in the background you can
see a castle which looks very similar to one of
doctor doom's castles in the comics in la verria
so a lot of people just thought that this town
that he wound up in was la verria and even in the
crates in the truck that he stole there was a von
doom seeming name now it wasn't von doom but a lot
of people thought that they did this on purpose
like we're gonna make it seem like von doom
because people are gonna think that even though
the name is meant to be a little bit different
and i just did a big doctor doom deleted scene
easter eggs video from dr strange too because
in the 838 universe sam raimi and the writer
of doctor strange too basically said that they
had a lot of doctor doom stuff going on in the
background like the john krasinski 838 universe
version of reed richards and the fantastic four
based his teleportation device on doctor doom's
classic time travel platform from the comics so
like in the 838 universe it's meant to be like
the most fanservicey comic bookie universe ever
paying off every single easter egg you ever wanted
to see in a marvel movie like everything you can
imagine exists in this universe they have their
own universe version of doctor doon that this
version of reed richards has already encountered
and that's how he came up with a lot of this
technology these portals that he created
they haven't officially confirmed doctor
doom or reed richards or the fantastic four
exist in the 616 universe yet but because the
logo on john krasinski's 838 costume is the exact
same fantastic four logo in the official trailer
that they released for the brand new movie that
they're making a lot of people think that when
they do the movie it'll be john krasinski just
playing a different version of the character they
even had easter eggs for fantastic four during
spider-man far from home at the end of the movie
when he swings past the tower which used to be the
avengers tower now a lot of people think might
wind up being a version of the baxter building
there's a construction sign that says we can't
wait to show you what happens next one two three
and then the four obviously is disappeared so
people think that that's meant to be a reference
to the fantastic four because all the different
colors correspond to the colors of the powers of
the people in the fantastic four in like the four
is invisible because it's meant to represent the
invisible woman and at the time it was just marvel
early on a couple years ago just winking at the
future like oh yeah we're definitely going to be
doing a fantastic four movie cut to a couple years
later when they announced oh yeah we're definitely
doing fantastic four and then they literally show
us john krasinski reed richards of the fantastic
four the only added change i think is that they're
going to try and use the multiverse as a bigger
plot point like the fantastic four movie might not
take place in the 616 universe it might be another
multiverse related movie and because their movie
schedule for the next couple years is just so book
solid with projects that they've announced they
don't really have time for a completely separate
doctor doom movie on top of the fantastic four
movie so if howard stern was meant to be filming
something this summer and it was doctor doom like
and he wasn't confused it's more likely that
that would be for a disney plus series but the
other thing that could have been happening is that
howard stern just got confused about which marvel
project he was supposed to be working on and what
he thought was doctor doom was either a totally
different movie or a disney plus series like it
could have been the actual fantastic four movie or
it could have been one of these marvel disney plus
series that they're filming for release next year
and as far as i know there's no surprise doctor
doom series that they're going to be releasing
episodes for next year that would be crazy
though marvel tends to use a lot of weird
working title names for a lot of its projects
so it's really easy for people like howard stern
to get confused about which marvel project
they're actually supposed to be working on
i've got a bunch of thor love and thunder videos
that i'm working on for next week so look out for
that but there was also some brand new ant-man in
avengers footage like new avengers footage that
leaked i'll do a video for that tomorrow i've
got a couple episode videos that i'm working
on because there's a couple big finales that are
happening make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of that everyone
click here to learn about all those doctor doom
easter eggs for the 838 universe version the
character in doctor strange 2 that sam raimi
was talking about and click here for my brand
new thor love and thunder in beta ray bill video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!